and I think the big problem is that
people expect that they're going to have
a perfect business I can't think of an
entrepreneur beside Chef Bezos who's a
freak of nature most people have a
graveyard of failures behind them the
idea is you start not with the intent of
saying this is going to be the one thing
for the rest of my life which is the
fallacy that employees have when in
relatives I just have to do a thing that
I'm good enough at that I can learn the
game and the thing is once you start
taking steps The Next Step becomes
illuminated you trying to think a
hundred steps into the future when you
have no context is irrelevant because
chaos is going to break your plan and a
lot of people think they need to have
some novel idea the best way to start a
business is just look at what everyone
else is doing and just try and do it
better what are things that I already
know how to do or I have past experience
in what things because I have past
experience I know that other people
struggle with that sucks about this
thing and then I will solve that
specific problem and it could also be a
problem that other people solve too you
just try and do a little bit better
hey friends and welcome back to Deep
dive the weekly podcast where every week
it is my immense privilege to sit down
with authors and academics and
entrepreneurs and creators and other
inspiring people and we talk about how
they got to where they are and the
strategies and tools that we can learn
from them to apply to our own lives to
help live our best lives now what you're
about to hear is an interview between me
and Alex hormozzi Alex has been
absolutely taking the Internet by storm
over the last year or two he's a
business owner I guess who's just he's
also absolutely jacked and just produces
loads and loads of content which is all
around helping you start and build a
business he and his wife Leila they own
businesses together their portfolio is
worth over 150 million dollars and Alex
has written an absolutely fantastic book
called 100 million dollar offers which
is a book basically all about how to
craft an offer which converts people and
which sells well and he's genuinely one
of the most inspiring people that I've
ever come across in the world of
Entrepreneurship he has nothing to sell
you that's like one of his one of his
selling points at his whole mission is
to help people start businesses because
starting a business and growing his
business was what allowed him to become
free and Get Ridiculous levels of wealth
and be able to do whatever you want on
it and so in the conversation we talk a
little bit about how let's say someone
working a normal job could potentially
be taking those first steps to start
that business which could potentially
allow them to quit that job if that's
what they want to do and we touch on a
bunch of other things around the
importance of learning versus owning
investing in the S P 500 versus the
sne500 and we explore a little bit of
Alex's backstory where he quays
corporate job and then started gyms and
like all of the various lessons I
learned along the way so I hope you
enjoyed this interview with Alex formosi
yeah so thank you so much for taking the
time um no this is a conversation I've
been looking forward to for a while
because I've uh discovered your stuff
around the time you were blowing up
seemingly on all of the social platforms
um and then and then I came across your
book and I listened to it on Audible and
around the same time all of my friends
had also discovered the book and they
were just like we were all messing being
like Oh my God have you read 100 million
offers it's just absolutely sick and
it's just like jam-packed with value so
firstly thank you for that um and for
providing that as a 99 service to the
world broadly
um how did you think about pricing for
that for that book by the way
I mean I think it's always like what's
the you know what problem are we solving
and so for me like the point of the book
is not to make money from the book the
point of the book was to you know help
as many businesses make money and then I
mean the the play fragments.com is a
very long play you know what I mean
which is just I believe that there's
lots of
there I think that the biggest inflow of
deals will actually come in five years
from all the people who've consumed the
stuff and have gotten to you know three
five ten twenty million and they want to
work with acquisition.com who are not at
that threshold yet
um but it's guys who want to go to 100
and they're capped at 10 and they're
trying to figure out what to do
um that's that's what I'm making all the
stuff for
um but yeah so the problem that we're
solving is like how do we get this and
as many hands as possible and so giving
it away for free I actually don't think
would have gotten as many hands because
I wanted to use because if Amazon makes
money Amazon will push it right and so I
did make and so at 99 Cents Amazon gets
two-thirds of the revenue from the thing
if I was at 299 then it's I get two
thirds and they get one third and so my
at least my men's argument was it's easy
to sell a 99 thing uh I can tap into the
traffic that Amazon will provide and
what problem am I solving which is mass
distribution you know as many people as
possible and I think there is also a
tiny element of free versus paid there's
like an emotional difference of like I
paid something I mean it's a difference
between a customer and a voyeur you know
what I mean and so
um that was that was at least the the
thought process behind it and um
yeah just that was that was it there
wasn't there wasn't too much more
thought than that
so one of the things that you open a lot
of your content with is
um the phrase to the effect of my name
is Alex Mosey I own acquisition.com uh
uh and I'm gonna help you get to 3
million in Revenue if you're more than
three million in Revenue then talk to me
I want to acquire you but if you're less
than three million in Revenue I want to
help you get there and I have nothing to
sell you
um and that's that's interesting so it's
it's interesting a because like the way
people were describing you when it was
sort of on the Grapevine when you first
started blowing up was that phrase that
and and I have nothing to sell you and
that was that really tapped nicely into
some something in the Zeitgeist where
everyone knows someone's always trying
to sell you something and then just the
fact that you're so blase about throwing
the word three million out there where
for most people they hear that number
and they like [ __ ] their pants because
like three million's a lot of money but
the way you seem to talk like it it's
it's almost like it's it's not and it
helped like for me at least helped me
change my mindset around multiple
Millions to the point is that it it
didn't seem like such a big deal so I
wonder if you can just kind of speak to
that a bit like what's the philosophy
behind the introduction yeah I mean so
many many of the things uh that I feel
like I've gotten some notoriety for have
been uh you know sheer accidents that
it's it's it only seems masterful in
retrospect then more than it was you
know um intelligent design
um I got frustrated because a lot of
people were like he's just trying to
sell a course this is like early on
um because you know and I was like I was
like I'm not I have nothing to sell you
I was like I have nothing to sell you
and so the very first dude I can't
remember which one it was I just said it
like I was just annoyed uh when I said
that and then you know the comments just
like poured on if it's like oh so I just
need to be more like more explicit about
this I people just don't know I was like
I have nothing I have a 99 cent book
like you know what I mean like if that
and that's actually the one thing that
I've struggled uh with is because like
the internet doesn't do well with Nuance
um and so they're like you know super
like he's trying to make money I'm like
dude like yeah and the book does make
money the book makes uh probably about
60 000 a month in income
um that I make from the book yeah
um so I mean like it makes money
um but like relative to my income it's
just like it's irrelevant like it
doesn't even you know what I mean like
it doesn't it doesn't my top employee
makes a million plus a year like it
doesn't do anything for me so
um it's just like for context right
um
so
um anyways all that say the thinking
processors more to me we're trying to be
explicit and in terms of talking about
three million I may even change it I may
I've changed it on some a lot of my
profiles to 10 million
um and up but
the biggest issue that most people have
between zero and three specifically
um is just ignorance
people just don't know what to do you
know what I mean so like just you know
getting to six figures is literally just
like sell something to someone like
that's that's all you have to do to get
six records like
one channel one product one Avatar like
that's it you don't have to do anything
else and then you know when you get you
want to get to Seven figures then you
just do that and then add the word
consistently which is you do you know
you input the inputs in the system in a
way that's consistent so that you get a
consistent output so it's whatever way
you acquire those customers whether it
was reach outs whether it was content
whether it was paid ads whether it was
Affiliates whether it was referrals
whatever the thing was that got you the
customers cool
do that consistently and you'll be in a
million you know what I mean which is
which is still only 20K a week it's not
like a huge number you know one to three
is usually uh increasing output of that
that main thing to a small degree
um and really just like Baseline
efficiencies and building out the core
team so usually at that point going one
to three is getting the person out of
delivery
um to a large you know to a large extent
and usually they get their first kind of
first follower first like one or two
uh I'm trying to think the right word to
how to say this
um competent individuals uh who are
helping them out and then you know a
handful of Frontline and so it's usually
like companies that's yeah three million
they're like five to Fifteen employees
and so and there's usually really only
like two-ish good ones um and the rest
are okay right and so at that point you
know going from three to ten is usually
where we can it's the minimum level that
we take people on and it's not because
there's something magical about three
million is that three million typically
checks two boxes box one is that they
have product Market fit at some level
people want something from them like
something they're selling is resonating
enough that they can generate sales and
the second thing I guess there's three
boxes one is that the second is that
they have at least one reliable
acquisition channel that they're
currently doing and the third is that
they have a core team in place so
they've demonstrated product Market fit
they have a reliable acquisition Channel
just at least one uh and they have a
core team in place which may be
relatively dysfunctional and have very
few key players but at least they have
some semblance of structure and so if
they have if they meet those minimum
requirements then we can at least start
from at least some level of Leverage
um to start helping them grow okay so
I'd love to talk a lot about that that
initial bit that you sort of threw away
with like oh one product one channel one
one yeah
um so forbid context a couple of weeks
ago I I happened to be on on vacation on
some Greek island and I posted an
Instagram reel of like hey this is the
creator life I'm working on my iPad and
stuff and there are a few comments from
people being like I'd love to live this
sort of Lifestyle but I just don't know
where to start and that sort of that
idea of I'd love to be able to
you know if we imagine 99.9 listening to
both people listening to this if you
told them they could make six figs a
year doing what they love they'd be like
mind blown would absolutely love that so
I wonder if we can kind of explore that
zero to six figure jump uh or sort of
process let's say someone has got a
full-time job let's say they're working
in I don't know consulting or some
Something Corporate and they love the
idea of I want to make a living doing
what I love how how would we break that
down and this is under the assumption
that they hate doing what they're doing
yes I was like because I I always like
to be clear I was like I've got
employees that make a million bucks a
year plus so like you can absolutely
become filthy wealthy and that's income
right and so a lot of businesses that
are at 10 million dollars a year the
owner might only take a million bucks in
income depending on you know margins Etc
and so like
a lot of a lot of employees will wish
for they see Top Line as income which is
just a very employee mindset
um they're like oh if I make six figures
a year I'll make six figures a year it's
like Well if you really want to make six
figures you gotta probably make 500
Grand a year
um you know I mean revenue wise at least
if you don't want to have just bought
yourself another job right because so
let's let's talk through this transition
so if you're an employee when you make
the switch you're still an employee
you're just employee of a different
business that you happen to own and you
are basically 100 of the expenses and so
the business itself actually makes it
money you as the sole employee of that
thing and the boss
um gets to call your own shots but you
were still the employee right so you're
wearing all the hats Etc
um and so it's relatively nuanced you
know I mean like if you had a six-pear
consulting job and then you start
Consulting on the side for example
through your own LLC you have the same
job you just got rid of the person who
is giving you Direction and now you are
responsible right the thing that most
people have to do is they have to go get
money right you have to go make money
and the way you do that is you sell
stuff right and the way that you can
even begin the conversation to sell
stuff is that you have to have people
who show interest in the thing which
means you have to make your products
known and we do that through advertising
right there's five ways to advertise a
child which I just went over earlier
um and so it's like pick one of those
five ways
start doing it on a consistent basis
bring people in what do you sell them
that's what 100 offers book is for it's
like this is how you figure out what to
sell
um and then you sell them the thing and
then after that you'll have some
delivery now usually if you have a
consistent method of advertising and
selling with a with a what to sell from
the offer then you can start getting
people to help you uh on the level of
delivery you have which comes down to
Breaking the delivery into chunks rather
than holistically and saying how can I
specialize the labor because you trying
to say I just need somebody to do what I
do is silly right you need to figure out
how could somebody do how can I get how
can I get five people to do 20 of what
I'm doing and do it consistently right
and then you can increase your
advertising sales is a very high
leverage thing in the beginning if you
spend all day selling just you you would
have enough for five people to do work
right and so then you would have a
business you know just a quick
announcement from one of our sponsors
and we'll get right back to the episode
and this episode is brought to you by
Heights Heights is a brain care smart
supplement that I've been taking every
morning for the last 12 months I love it
so much that I actually became friends
with the founder Dan who we actually had
on season one of the Deep dive podcast
we also have an interview this season
with neuroscientist and psychiatrist Dr
Tara swart who's the chief science
officer of heights and I like the
product so much that I actually became
an angel investor in the company it's
great everything they do is completely
evidence-based so on their website
they've got a list of all 20-something
micronutrients that they've got in these
two capsules along with links to all of
the various scientific papers and
consensuses on why these sorts of
nutrients are good for you and why
they've got them at the appropriate
dosing which they have in the capsules
in the capsules it's super easy to sign
up you just go on the website which is
linked in the show notes and in the
video description and you put in your
address and they send you one of these
little boxes of pills every month or
every quarter now I sign up to the
quarterly subscription so I get three of
these every three months and the
quarterly subscription is great because
a it's discounted from the monthly
subscription and B if you use the coupon
code Ali 15 ali15 at checkout then
you'll get an extra 15 off the already
discounted price of the quarterly
subscription now obviously it's ideal if
you can actually get all these
micronutrients from your diet that would
be the gold standard but as studies show
99 of us in the Western World don't in
fact have the absolutely perfect gold
standard Mediterranean diet I certainly
don't I eat a lot of takeaways and so
these two capsules just two capsules
Every Morning has my base is covered and
it's a lot easier to take just two
little capsules with water than it is to
try and drown green sludge or whatever
else other other companies have in the
market that kind of does the same thing
so anyway thank you so much Heights for
sponsoring this episode and let's get
right back to the podcast so let's say
someone's listening to this and they're
thinking all right cool I know I like
I've realized this bookie he's telling
me I've got I've got a seller thing I
don't I don't know what to sell I don't
know if I have any skills I don't I
don't I don't know what I could possibly
offer to the world yeah how do we how do
we break that down
yeah this is actually a topic that I um
I cover more in the leads book that's
coming out soon uh soon relative terms
six months-ish
everybody knows something all right and
so the idea is what do you have like
everyone has unique depth of knowledge
in certain areas because you've been
alive and your eyes and ears have taken
inputs period right and so I like to
think of of people starting like so if
you look at are you familiar with black
combinator
yeah but so yeah yeah so why combinator
is one of the most successful you know
uh I don't know if they're technically
VC there's you know seed Capital startup
investors in Silicon Valley and they
have a very standard gel structure and
they have criteria for what they look
for in companies and one of the most
important criteria that they look for is
past experience and so they're okay with
somebody who's super young Etc but they
wanna they want you to have experience
in the industry because there's just so
much ignorance debt that you have to pay
down if you literally know nothing about
an industry like there's just so much
like if your dad was a mechanic you know
so much about cars just by osmosis of
being around a mechanic for 18 years and
so I like to think
past jobs you've held you will know
stuff about that industry
the jobs of your parents are things that
you will know about that industry and
then you've got personal interests and
so I think that if I put those into
three buckets it's like parent stuff
past jobs of self and current interests
and so it's like of those three things
which of those three buckets do you
think you could help someone do a thing
better
and so the idea is
you want to sell the most valuable thing
right and so the most valuable thing is
what is the problem that I can help
somebody else solve that I could charge
the most money for or in reverse that
could make them the most money and then
I will be able to charge a percentage of
the money that I'm able to make somebody
else in this thing now that's in a B2B
setting in a b2c setting it would be how
valuable do people perceive uh the
problem that they have as right whether
it's like I can teach music tons of
people want to be able to learn how to
and if you're better you know because
you've had a side interest in that
awesome maybe you have a side interest
because you're really good at editing
the songs well there's tons of musicians
who would love who hate that part and
would love to have them so it's like we
all know how to do stuff and all we have
to do is package the thing that we're
doing and I think the big problem is
that people expect that they're going to
have a perfect business but if you look
at the track record of all of I can't
think of an entrepreneur beside Chef
Bezos who's a freak of nature whose
first business becomes the most valuable
business in the world is most people
have a graveyard of failures behind them
and so the idea is you start not with
the incentive saying this is going to be
the one thing for the rest of my life
which is the fallacy that employees have
that whatever they pick as me they think
they're gonna do for the rest of their
lives when in relatives I just have to
do a thing that I'm good enough at that
I can learn the game and the thing is
once you start taking steps The Next
Step becomes illuminated you trying to
think 100 steps into the future when you
have no context is is irrelevant because
chaos is going to break your plan
anyways and so do what you know exchange
I like service businesses to start
because they are the in my opinion the
lowest risk to start because you're just
it's just your time right so service
businesses meaning do stuff for money
clean houses like whatever like all of
those are just service businesses right
and they're fine and a lot of people
think they need to have some novel idea
to start a business when I mean the best
in my opinion if you're if you're
getting into it the best way to start a
business is just look at what everyone
else is doing and just try and do it
better like that I mean and there's
obvious holes like if you've if you've
gone to if you've gotten your dry
cleaning it's like can I do this in half
the time as this guy if I do the lawn
care what are the things people hate
about lawn care they leave the the
trimmings around the edges they're all
shitty the person doesn't speak English
that well like well cool then I've got
advantages right so it's like what are
things that I already know how to do or
I have past experience in what things
because I have past experience I know
that other people struggle with that
sucks about this thing and then I will
solve that specific problem and it could
also be a problem that other people
solve too you just try and do a little
bit better like it's it's just not
rocket science you know what I mean and
then you exchange you start selling your
time for money so yes you're still
trading time for dollars you don't need
to read Rich that poor dad just yet
right you're still trading time for a
dollar
right but the point is that you're
you're you're trading that time for
money in order to learn not to earn you
need to earn in order to pay your pay
your rent eat Etc but the the major
thing you're doing is you're paying down
ignorance debt so the vast majority of
your income is coming in the terms of in
the form of Education rather than
earning yeah there's a few a few things
that I think are really interesting uh
the first is that um I think if if we
think of sort of how an employee thinks
of us as how an entrepreneur thinks
we're a business owner an employee sort
of mindset is often sort of the activity
that I'm doing where the entrepreneur is
more like the problem the specific
problem that I'm solving
um and I found that when people in in
our team have started doing freelance
work and now they have more of an idea
of what a creative business looks like
and they can solve a specific problem
they're just like oh my God it's so easy
to make money whereas before they were
thinking of this service as like oh I am
I I offer writing as a service or
something like that but as soon as you
connect it to a problem that preferably
a business has because businesses can
pay for it suddenly the eyes light up
and you realize hang on what does money
even mean if I could if it's seemingly
so easy to make it
um yeah I I like what you're saying
about service based businesses because
it's it's not that sexy like when you
hear people on podcasts you don't tend
to hear of someone who built a service
based business and it went pretty big
you tend to hear the stories of like the
tech entrepreneurs that build it in the
built in Innovative product and stuff
um they don't see the 100 failed
startups like the failure rate on Tech
startups it might like is just as high
as everything else except it usually
takes capital and it doesn't take
Capital to start service business so
with you like my understanding is that
you quit your corporate job
um and started that started the gym
business and I wonder if we can kind of
explore explore the story there a little
bit more I can actually even rewind that
there was a half step in between there
so this is also covered in the leads
book but I'll give a I'll give a sneak
peek so what I did
um is I actually because I'd been
interested in Fitness right that was my
interest so like I had past experience I
I was obsessed with Fitness I've been at
that point I was 23. I've been training
for eight years I had several State
records so like I was a pretty you know
I was pretty into it right and it was to
the point where people were asking me
for stuff all you know workout programs
and things like just because they knew
my interest right and so as a as a quick
you know Pro tip for everybody if you've
got stuff that people ask you to do for
them because you're good at it maybe
you're good at Tech it's like can you
help me set up my like Wi-Fi and stuff
you know blah blah blah it's like that
means you're solving problems you can
chart like what people ask you to do as
a favor is an indication of the things
you can charge for later right so
I had all these people who are asking me
uh not all these I mean I had a full
people who had asked me for programs and
stuff and so what I did was during my
last year of Consulting I started
something called the free training
project and so the free training project
was I would charge 500 to a thousand
dollars but I would I wouldn't charge it
they had to donate that to the charity
their choice in exchange to work with me
right and so that way I wanted people to
Value it but they weren't paying me
directly so they'd get it right off they
felt good I had a ton of Goodwill also
in the marketplace too because I was
like I'm doing all this stuff for
charity I got I got all these people
reaching out to me like this is so cool
blah blah blah right
and so after a year of doing that I had
probably I don't know 12 really good
test of like great before and after
pictures that I had collected from my
clients and I told them that was part of
the deal I was like I'll like you have
to donate it I would like to do this for
real later but
um you have to let me use your
testimonial and they were like that's
fine so once I had that
um I had those first you know 10 12
customers who had who had great before
and after pictures
um I transitioned many of those
customers said hey I'm doing I'm going
to do this full time now are you
comfortable paying the same amount
you're paying to charity except just
making a charity of Alex because Alex
can't eat either and so and that was
actually how I transitioned from
not-for-profit or donating everything
and I'd even set up there today I just
told them to to literally donate it and
send me the screenshot I didn't even do
anything like that
um and so I didn't have a website
all I had was an LLC and a PayPal
account so like for everybody's like I
don't know how to start a business I was
like you literally just need a bank
account and a way to process money that
is it like two things and you can Google
how to figure out if you can't figure it
out from Google entrepreneurship might
not be for you all right but you look
like think about there's 30 million
business in the United States 30 million
other people have figured this out
which means you can too so bank account
payment processing make the first 10
free or some sort of charitable thing so
that people like don't feel weird or you
don't feel weird about selling Etc after
you have it after you're providing the
service to people you can transition
people from free service to paid service
and if they don't want to start paying
you then that gives you insight as to
either you suck right or they suck which
is also possible too but either way
a certain percentage of those people
will continue to stay and pay and now
you have income now you can also ask
those people for referrals which is
exactly what I did
um so I think half that business came in
just for I got you know the initial ones
came in from friends and family and me
posting and so I was I'll I'll close the
loop on what I said earlier a year later
after I had that testimonials I made a
public post being like hey I've got this
thing now I made a website which is that
was my big enough I made a website I
still have the post I found it it's
2013. I was like I made it I made a
website and uh I I am now open for
business and so if you would like you
know training stuff let me know
um this is what I'm doing now you know I
had some testimonials and go check out
the site whatever and so from there I
was able to get I think about 20 guys uh
who were willing to let me do just like
almost bodybuilding type stuff because I
was kind of like what I was powerless
back then and so
um I think I want to say I got 20 guys
at 200 bucks a month and so I was making
four thousand dollars a month
uh from those people and it took me four
hours every Saturday to do the
Fulfillment what was the Fulfillment I
would just I would just update their
training programs and and send them
nutrition uh like update their macros
updated meal plans
um and then like you know new workouts
before the week Etc
um and then I and everyone had my cell
phone and I would just text them the new
stuff and if they had any questions they
could hit me up like it was a very
simple business
um and so that's what I did it was just
one-on-one online and it only took me
four hours on Saturday morning and to
show you what kind of person I am I
hated it uh even though I loved Fitness
I hated having to do something the same
thing every day
um like on the delivery side so I ended
up having the genius idea of saying oh I
need to own a gym because then I'll be a
business owner I'm really just
self-employed right now
um and so that's what got me to start my
gym rather than probably doing the wiser
decision and saying okay this cost you
four hours a week and you're making four
grand a month maybe you should do this
for 40 hours a week but doing more of it
to me felt like a horrible idea so I
didn't want to do anymore
um so how did you jump from that to
therefore I should probably own a gym oh
I don't think that's that's the
difference yeah it was not a good it was
not an intelligent one I always thought
I was going to own a gym that was I mean
that was the not always I had done a so
so these are the three things that I was
deciding between for my business I was
decided between a test prep company
because I was really good at
standardized testing
um and I had a process for how I how I
did it I had a yogurt business idea
because I was a big yo Froyo guy yeah I
know I was like I'm a Avid consumer of
this [ __ ] yeah I feel like I know and I
and I hate it there's so many things I
knew that I thought I could I actually
know a lot about the other business now
um and I was going to finish so those
are the three things that I felt like I
could do for anybody's listening like
those are the three that I was picking
between the yogurt business cost 250
Grand to start up I didn't have that
money so I couldn't do that one
um I had saved about 50 or 60 Grand I
can't remember 50 or 60 at the time
um I was 23. and then uh the test prep
business I actually did a ton of work on
um and I was going to partner with a
professor from my University to do it
with me and so I set up all the initial
materials
um and based on a miscommunication I'll
just put it that way
um he ended up either taking the
materials and not and using them without
me to start a business Consulting thing
either way it became clear that what I
thought was happening versus what he
thought was happening were not the same
thing
um and that left a very sour taste in my
mouth with test prep I do think it was
the smarter business I probably should
have done
um and so all that was left was Fitness
and so Fitness I was like I already know
that uh people already want me to help
them with it so I'll just start that and
so the gym was the that was the what uh
what I would have said is like the legit
business I didn't think that the online
thing was legitness remember this is 10
years ago
so like it wasn't what I don't even
thought it was that was a that was a
concept of legitimate business you know
what I mean so I was really early days
on it and so uh you know from there I
hit up 40 gym owners uh to see if I
could just basically Apprentice for them
and just work for free uh one guy hit me
back he had a mastermind uh I joined his
Mastermind for ten thousand dollars even
though I didn't have a gym and I said
are you sure that it makes sense for me
to join he's like oh yeah sure
um and it did actually make sense for me
because then I could learn from all the
mistakes everybody else was making
before I started so I was like okay this
works and so I learned all the stuff
that I could from that Mastermind and
from him
um he ended up signing guys yeah there's
actually a couple questions on that
front yeah so um yeah the the test prep
thing is interesting I didn't I didn't
know that part of the story so my first
business that went well was also a test
prep business and I still have the
Evernote document from 2012 where I was
like [ __ ] I need to make some money what
am I good at uh and what could I
possibly do and it was like test prep
and web design I was like cool let me
make a test press of course thing and
let me advertise it on a website because
back then it was hard to make a website
look pretty and that that's what ended
up ended up making the money initially
um on the on the gym front so
it it seems to me like there's two leaps
there
um leap number one is I want to do this
thing like I start a gym maybe
um and therefore I'm gonna work for free
I wanted to own a business yeah I want
to own a business therefore I'm going to
work for someone for free that that is
seems like a bit of a leap uh which
these days seems very unfashionable to
even say because everyone then goes down
your throat for being that's only
available for the privilege etc etc
privilege working for fun yeah the
working for free thing it's it's quite
unfashionable to suggest that people
work for free
um at least I mean I was making four
grand a month from my little online
thing so I made money from that now I
offered to work for free but I he
quickly was like I don't feel good about
it I'll just pay you and so he paid me
he paid me like minimum wage but I mean
I think I made like I don't know 2 800
bucks a month whatever it was I don't
even remember what it was because I made
more from the four hours a week on
Saturday than I did from that but again
but the point wasn't to to to earn you
know I mean it was to learn and I had
saved up 50 Grand so I knew I could live
for you know at least two years on that
um I tried to live when I was I was I
spent 400 bucks a month splitting a
bedroom
um and then I ate not you know I spent a
hundred dollars a week on food I was
eating you know I was spending nothing
to live and then the rest of my time was
at the gym trying to learn just a quick
message from one of our sponsors and
we'll get right back to the episode and
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by short form short form is the
world's best service that summarizes
books but it's way more than just book
summaries they almost have a whole study
guide for every book that they've got on
the platform where they've got a
one-page summary and then they also have
chapter by chapter breakdowns and it's
not just chapter by chapter breakdowns
also in between the chapter breakdowns
they have interactive exercises where
you can engage more readily with the
ideas in the book short form covers
non-fiction books from a bunch of
different genres that you might be
interested in for example they've got a
load of stuff in the business world so
if for example you're an entrepreneur or
you want to become an entrepreneur
that'll be great for you they've got
books in motivation they've got books in
education they've got books in lifestyle
and communication basically any genre of
like non-fiction personal development is
self-helpy stuff that will help you
level up your life it's all there on
short form short form Publishers new
book guides and articles every week and
if you're a subscriber then you get to
vote on what book they cover next and in
fact through the that system I have
voted for various books for example one
book I've recently rediscovered is on
writing well by William zinser now this
is a book I actually read absolutely
ages ago and I read it and I thought oh
wow this is really really good and I'd
actually forgotten I'd read it until I
saw that this was actually covered on
short form and so I went on the app on
my phone I usually go on short form when
I'm on the toilet if I'm feeling
particularly productive and I saw oh my
God they've got on writing well on here
and so I Revisited the key ideas which I
immediately applied to the Articles and
to the book that I'm writing anyway if
any of that sounds up your street and
you would like to sign up to the world's
best service that summarizes books then
head over to shortform.com forward slash
Deep dive and that will give you a
completely free five-day trial and you
can try out the service to your heart's
content that link will also be in the
video description and in the show notes
and thank you so much short form for
sponsoring this episode the thing that's
always struck me about you like when
I've when I've heard other interviews is
that you're so matter of fact about all
of this stuff and wears to me like at
every stage of the journey I know people
who are at that point who have gone the
other way and decided you know what oh I
couldn't I couldn't possibly leave my
40K a year job even though I'm living
with my parents and I don't have any any
kids or anything I couldn't possibly
leave that and take a pay cut because
that would be bad and you're supposed to
make more money as you go older rather
than less and yeah do you kind of get
that problem like uh I guess the sorts
of people you speak to these days are
mostly the sort of three to ten million
plus rather than the people they're just
struggling to get started but I imagine
most of the people that follow you tend
to be in the beginner Camp 88 so what if
you can how do you know that uh we have
a survey on our site oh yeah nice yes 88
of people uh want to start a business at
least that follow me so I wonder if you
can speak more to this idea of like
learn versus earn
um because I think that's a good model
and this idea of paying down ignorance
debt I think I think that's a great
model that more people could yeah it's
the most expensive cost every like right
now everybody it costs everybody costs
me a billion dollars a year to not be to
not know what to do to make a billion
dollars or I do know how to make a
billion dollars and I just have to wait
and pay down my time debt which is what
I feel like I'm doing right now just
paying down time and so I think
understanding whether it's a lack of
knowledge or or it's just a timeline
thing like those are big differences you
know I mean at the Baseline right you
could be doing the right thing you could
just be 10 years behind when it's going
to come to fruition you will get
outsized Returns on the on the
information right on the knowledge and
the lessons that you will learn and so
you want to you want to pay that
ignorance down as fast as you can
because as soon as you have that
knowledge you'll be able to Skyrocket
straight to
20 50 100 500 000 a month like very
quickly because you know how to do it
right so people are like getting
obsessed about these micro changes when
the big scheme changes like this is why
in my opinion all of the money that
someone would be spent and like this is
relatively controversial
um it's a whole S P 500 versus SME 500
but like you will get a significantly
higher return investing in your own
ability to make money than you will in
any any market and so if you look at all
the the vast majority of very very
wealthy people they have tremendous
earning capacity right they know how to
do stuff that makes money right so it's
like we got to go get that and so
there's really not like if you were to
if you were at a dollar cost average a
thousand dollars a month into the S P
500 for for you know 50 years sure you'd
also not live a fun life but you could
do that if you wanted to you could do
that you absolutely could right
um
or you could take that thousand dollars
a month join a mentorship program every
year you know what I mean this is why my
whole argument against like college is
not that I'm against College I think
it's just overpriced and so you could
take 200 like you want to you want to
have a Trippy thought
Inc like in the US you can get a student
loan for the full amount of college
about 200 000 if you go to like a really
nice private school like that's that
that's what you can get subsidized
through the government 200 000 and you
don't have debt payments for like a very
long time
here's a crazy thought you could take
that two hundred thousand dollars you
could buy a [ __ ] rental property that
makes you four thousand dollars a month
and then you would literally exit the
system before you even got into it with
the money that they're giving you to
become a worker which is just fat and
you wouldn't even have to pay the pay
Down The Debt Service for the real
estate a buddy of mine did this he's a
PhD student he got grants to go to
school he still took out the student
loans and he finished uh finished his
his PhD with 20 homes and ten thousand
dollars a month of income from from
doors that he didn't even have Debt
Service on because it was it was student
loans
crazy just as a fun side vessel yeah I
know so but but I won't even get into
that one but if we just think okay I'm
paying two thousand dollars a month if
I'm paying if I if I if I if I'm working
for not working if I'm going to school
for 25 000 a year it's 100 grand for
four years whatever
I pay 2 000 a month is there another
place that I could spend two thousand
dollars a month and get a superior
return on my ability to earn money and
my argument would be yes there are many
places most places arguably will give
you a better return on your money than a
traditional four-year degree at this
moment right and so you take the you
take the two thousand dollars a month
you go and you buy a six month
Mastermind on placing ads you buy a six
month thing on selling you buy a six
month thing on making courses whatever
maybe it takes you 18 months well you're
still two and a half years ahead of the
other guys
so what you know what I mean yeah I
think this is this is like a key a key
like mindset shift because I'm just
thinking there's so many conversations
I've had with friends and people in my
audience over the over the years where
it's like you know they've got like a
regular job maybe earning 50k or
something and they're like oh or even
30k like whatever and they're like I I
know I want to make some money on the
side therefore
um you know talk to me about investing I
I've I like do I pick stocks or index
funds and I'm like I mean Index Fund but
like the hangers how much money how much
money do you make yeah you're poor
there's no like you're not gonna make
you're not gonna make breathtaking in
the thing and here's here's the thing is
when you when you do the dollar cost
average thing because everyone likes to
put in the Excel sheet everyone gets
Excel Rich the thing is is that by the
time you retire with four million
dollars on that Excel sheet four million
dollars will be a million dollars today
which is not a lot of money
now people are like there is a lot of
money it's not when you're trying to
live on it and you got like 30 more
years to live it's not it's not a lot of
money right and that's in you know I
mean like it's it's just if you just
take take the compounding of four
percent a year on inflation and do that
for 40 years and then see what the money
really looks like right like people
aren't taking the inflation into account
and that's just not because it's hot
topic now that's just always whatever it
is I think it's around four percent it's
been the compounding rate of inflation
and so
point is and this is the simplest
example I have that can illustrate the
concept the same PhD guy that good
friend of mine he is a daughter his
daughter got a job at a bowling alley
minimum wage she just you know lets
people to the tables and gets some shoes
or whatever it doesn't matter
she could spend 500 and get a weekend
certification to become a phlebotomist
our phlebotomists draw blood for people
all right all you need is a two-day
certification so you get the
certification cost 500 bucks her earning
capacity would go from Seven dollars an
hour to 25 an hour
just from that one thing so she has two
options she could wait eight weeks save
up the money and then spend the money on
their certification right and then her
earning capacity would go up it would
triple immediately
or
she could borrow the money from her
parents and then do it that weekend pay
the money back the next week from the
earnings that you had and then and then
be seven weeks ahead of her other other
path right
or she could save up to 500 and put in
the S P 500 and make two dollars and
fifty cents a year
nice
and so the and so the thing is they're
they're making these these these
assumptions and they're just not
thinking through the math which is like
the problem they have is they don't make
enough money they have an income problem
they don't have an investing problem
right the nice thing is that if you're
poor right now means you have learned
how to live on less which is a good
habit so keep living on not a lot but
then this is where like this is where I
don't understand people because like my
my plan B for like if the gym didn't
work because you have to like for me
it's always risk mitigation so plan B
was
um if I didn't want to do the
entrepreneurship thing after that I'd
have a good story for business school so
that was that was one path which they
love you know having people try stuff
whatever the other path was and this is
probably the real path as soon as I
started I knew I wasn't going to go back
um was that I would strip at night and I
would drive Uber so if I drove over
during the day I could make I and if I
drove all day if I drove 12 hours a day
I could make like 80 90 grand a year if
I just did that and then at night in
four or five hours I could probably pull
another 150 in and so I could make 250
000 a year just stripping and driving
Uber maybe even more
now once I got the first level of skills
so I learned how to sell I realized that
my base levels my base level opportunity
Rose because then I was like I could
just sell cars and make 400 000 a year
and keep my clothes on
right I could sell cars and then I
wouldn't have to stress so that became
my my you know my new Baseline now once
I knew how to once I knew how to Market
and sell then my new Baseline became
actually what started which which became
my my inner intermediary model between
when I owned my chain of gyms and when I
started doing gym launches when I flew
out and would do the turnkey sales
system because I knew how to Market I
knew how to sell and so what I did was I
would just run ads I would spend the
money on the ads I would get the leads I
would work the leads I'd sell the leads
and I I kept all the cash
so when I did that on my own no
employees I'd make 100 a month
like zero employees I mean I had to work
14 hours a day but that's all I did if I
did that for a month I would make 100
grand
and so that became my new Baseline right
of how much I could make on my own and
so like my Baseline has continued to
rise as my skill set has improved
um and so I could go down that
trajectory but basically going back to
the girl going back to the girl a lot of
people are in the girl's position and
are saying I am going to save my 500
over the next eight weeks and try and
earn
two and a half to five dollars a year on
that money when they should be trying to
solve the problem how do I create
another fifty thousand dollars a year in
income well let me let me like boom she
can triple earning capacity and if she
lives on the same 750 she now has a
thousand dollar whatever that is 25 an
hour times times two thousand she's
making fifty Grand a year so now she can
still live at her parents house have
thirty thousand dollars a year and for
thirty thousand dollars a year you can
buy any education you want in the world
any skill you want is available for
thirty thousand dollars a year any any
sub 10 million dollar skill I'll put it
that way so with a girl we we want to
spend money on increasing our our
ability to earn more rather than trying
to screw around with three percent
returns in the S P 500 yeah so hence uh
sort of when you're when you're working
for free and maybe I don't know taking a
bit of a pay cut apprenticing for
someone else you're understanding you're
learning how the business works and
you're learning how specifically that
business Works I.E the gym business
because you maybe wanted to own your own
business and you were interested in
Fitness and you're also learning how
generally business Works through like
sales marketing operations all of that
sort of stuff
um so what happened next in in your
story yeah so I joined the Mastermind
and then he quickly was like you know
what I'm asking it felt weird for him to
not pay me because I was just there all
the time so he started paying me
whatever it was minimum wage
um and so I was there from 4 AM to 4pm
every day with them so that was that was
what we did so 4 AM to 4 pm I was there
with them every day and then he would go
home I would stay for a few more hours
to just like work out hang out at the
gym so I was pretty much there all day
every day and then uh for the next I
think 12 weeks that's what I did is I
just you know hung around the gym uh
learned learned how to sell learned how
stuff worked learned that email like
learn I learned sales was a thing I
didn't know the term sales I didn't know
email lists existed like I didn't know
any of this stuff like I truly had no
idea how any of this stuff worked and so
I learned a lot very quickly just from
observing normal business happening
right and I think small businesses are
more useful for people to be at because
like corporate it's so specialized
because the cover is so big you have
such a myopic view of how business works
you have no idea you are actually the
very special Cog that does one thing
right so you don't see the holistic you
wear a small business is because
everything's so shrunk down you can see
end to end how things work it's like we
do this we do this direct mail piece a
certain percentage call call phone we
set the appointment they buy a
membership they go to the trainer who
helps them like you know what I mean
like you can see the whole life cycle
right
so 12 weeks later I was do it every
weekend I would go out and look for uh
locations uh when I found location that
I liked I still had my 50 Grand saved up
um and so then that's what I spent I
spent I think most of that to outfit the
facility I think I had 10 000 left over
um because I knew I had two months worth
of rent uh saved up which is 5 000 a
month in rent and I had and honestly in
retrospect it was one of the riskiest
things I've ever done like I went
straight to a five thousand dollar a
month lease and I had no idea what I was
doing that's a lot for rent oh I'd never
even made money before I mean like I
didn't it was funny because I can only
think about this in retrospect but like
the the the online business that I had I
didn't have a reliable way of getting
customers I just like the people that I
knew and I immediately was making money
from that but I wasn't keeping everyone
always and they're starting to go down I
was like oh what do I do so I was like
I'll just sign a lease for way more
money than I've ever made in my life
um that sounds like a reasonable thing
to do
and so that's what I did
I wonder if we can zoom into the sales
thing a little bit because I think
selling is a massive black box for a lot
of people and even for me like when I
first started actually selling stuff
I've been doing YouTube for five years
but you know yeah I don't feel like I
was selling anything for the first three
because it was all like sponsorships and
you kind of and then sort of two two
years ago when I had an idea for like a
course that teaches people how to be
YouTubers
um I came up against so much like
internal like mental friction around the
idea of selling and feeling weird about
it and like then realized sales is a
thing so I wonder what was your
experience sort of on the ground in the
gym how did you learn how to sell yeah I
hated everything in the sales and the
Side Story that was that when I quit my
job my dad's body was a uh or my dad my
dad's Financial his investor dude right
the guy who managed this money uh was
like dude you should just come work for
me he's like you can sell and I was like
me I was like I'm an academic
all right I'm uh I'm a cerebral thinker
I'm a Management Consultant like that I
am known for you know I am not a
Salesman like that was my thing and so I
was like I was I thought it was beneath
me I really didn't and so anyways I got
the job
um I I did the interviews got the job
and I ultimately like they told me what
it was and it was like here's the phone
here's names bang and I was like oh I
don't want to do that so then I started
my gym and I realized that I had to pay
five thousand dollars a month and then
it was like the first day and I was like
oh [ __ ] how do I get people to give me
money I was like oh
sales and so it was a it was a forcing
function so I had gone to a weekend
Workshop that I spent three thousand
dollars for which was a tremendous
amount of money for me at the time
um
to go learn how to run Facebook ads it's
2013.
so I learned how to run Facebook ads in
that weekend
um and I ran Facebook ads for my gym and
that was when people came in I signed up
27 people the first two weeks uh I
charged 300 bucks ahead
I think I spent a thousand bucks on ads
so I made you know spent a thousand made
8 700 or whatever it was
um
and that was that was how that's how I
paid my first month's rent and my my
selling was just literally I had an
empty gym with no equipment it was a
Turf and a table
and they were like are you gonna be here
is this like a scam I was like No And
people just believe me I was like I
promise I will do everything to get you
in the best shape ever
and they were like
are you sure like I'd have some people
come back like two days later like make
sure I was still there
um in the two-week period And I also
didn't understand a lot of stuff like I
I thought I had to open as fast as
possible because I wanted I thought that
opening meant that I would make money
when really I should have had a really
long pre-sale just collected cash the
whole time like I didn't know any of
that stuff worked so I just tried to
open as fast as I could that was I had
my first 27 clients and I and I taught
all those sessions so I was doing six
sessions a day
um and then I would run ads I'd have
sales appointments then I'd clean the
gym and then I would do all my billing
at night
um and then work the lead like it was I
was I was it was the hardest I've ever
worked
time-wise like I've never I've still to
this day never worked that hard it was
uh okay yes let's zoom in to some of
these so you had the idea of like I want
to start a gym he works in a gym for
free for and then minimum wage for a
while so you understand how how AGM
works and then were you just like
roaming around looking for a warehouse
that you could convert into a gym yeah
and then you signed a lease for five
thousand dollars a month you're like all
right cool I now have a box I need to
put some gym equipment in there so you
put some gym equipment in there you take
a Facebook ad Workshop over the weekend
you spend three grand on it um and that
helps you run ads in your local area
that says hey by the way new gym opening
yeah something or other and then people
walking through the door and then what
happens when people walking through the
door do you just say hey this is this is
the gym can you give me your money or
how what is that I had an offer I had an
offer which was a six week challenge I
said if you lose because it was similar
to my whole charity thing where I wanted
people to like have skin in the game so
it was uh if you lose 20 pounds six
weeks I'll give you your money back
so people would bet it was 300 bucks I
would train them for six weeks and if
they lost 20 pounds I'd give them their
money back
so that was a stick
so are you relying on then people not
completing it to make money or no the
real real is there yeah so so you've got
you've got three buckets right you got
people who don't hit it right which is
actually not the bucket you want people
in because then they're not happy
um the second bucket is people who hit
it and then have more weight to lose or
want to keep working out because they
just started this habit and want to keep
going which is the vast majority I think
we had just under an 80 success rate and
then the third bucket is people who want
to lose the weight and then say I'll
take my money please right and the sale
is actually very easy I mean you're just
like hey
do you think that working out six weeks
and then going back to not working out
is uh is going to be a good long-term
solution no okay we'll wanna ride to
take your 300 bucks I'll credit score
it's the next year staying at the gym
because now you've started this habit
you don't want to lose it when you have
the momentum and they say sure cool and
I had people commit to the year before
they even finish the challenge halfway
through I feel like you like everything
everything cool you're 10 pounds down
awesome you're halfway there so I mean
how much weight do you want to lose
because I promise you once you're 10
pounds lighter you are now you're still
going to want to look different like
you're not going to be perfect I've yet
to meet somebody who's a perfect body
you're still gonna have stuff you want
to work on right they're like yeah of
course I'm like okay so question is you
want to do it on your own because that's
what you were doing before this and that
wasn't working or do you want to do with
me
they're like I want to do with you and
I'm like cool I'll take the money I'll
credit it for it so you won
congratulations high five big hug you
won it you get it because the point of
the challenge is not for you to actually
lose the weight is for you to understand
it's a lifelong process not six weeks
that was it that was the whole process
how did you do the Transformations like
how do people lose 10 20 pounds in six
weeks it's all food
okay so you're giving the meal plan yeah
I would give a meal plan's grocery list
for Preparation instructions eating out
guides the whole thing I'd give them a
whole custom thing and then they'd work
out at the gym uh originally it was five
days a week and then I switched to three
days a week
um but yeah and so that's your offer so
the offer isn't like a monthly gym
membership it's just like hey get into
the weight loss challenge you do the
thing and then you're signing up people
as they walk through the door yep I and
what what happened is I like and I still
do like this in terms of businesses in
generals I do like having to find in
programs on the front end because it
gives a very specific outcome uh for
someone on a specific timeline and what
it really becomes is your onboarding
process
so you can typically charge more for a
one-time expense usually three or four
times more than you can on a recurring
basis and so what that affords you is
the ability to liquidate acquisition
costs more easily and so it's like if I
can charge four times more for the first
six weeks of service with somebody I
should do that because it costs me more
a to onboard someone B to acquire them
and so I should make more money in that
first period of time it makes sense and
so structuring business models that way
it's I've almost done that in every
business I have got it
um did you feel weird about selling
initially no I was begging for money I
needed the money right I got over it
very quickly I mean it was just like I
had this ethical I had this like uh I'm
I'm superior I'm not going to lower
myself to selling and then I was like oh
[ __ ] I'm gonna lose all the money I have
and so I didn't even know it was sales I
just said like I will help you I promise
yeah please
you know like I didn't know what I was
doing but the thing is I you know I I
done 4 000 sales consults before I ever
consumed a piece of sales training
so like a lot of the stuff I got I
learned most of things I've learned
through just doing it
um
and uh just on this notes so you paid
three thousand dollars for a Facebook
ads weekend workshoppy type thing
um these days somewhere sort of tip
almost 10 years on from that do you
think there's value in people paying for
something like that or can everything
just be learned on YouTube and there's
no point in paying for a thing yeah I
think things can get you learned on
YouTube I think what you pay for is
speed
so you pay for Speed you pay for trouble
troubleshooting you pay for somebody
else who's already done it and not
[ __ ] up as many times as you're about
to to get you there faster like I
remember most of I've I've paid for tons
of one-on-one stuff so I had a guy who
had a course this is later this probably
two three years later I didn't I knew
enough to make you know to get ads going
but like I really did I wasn't like a
genie at it I just knew enough to get
lead so I could sell them
um but a few years later I wanted to get
more sophisticated I wanted to learn how
to retarget I didn't know any of that
stuff and so I paid a guy who had a
course he said I don't do one-on-one I
only do courses I don't sell my time and
I was like it's America everyone sells
their time just tell me what the price
is went back and forth and finally it
was like 750 an hour and I was like done
cool and I think I did eight sessions
with them so it cost me like 5 600 bucks
and because I didn't want to learn how
to run ads I want to learn how he would
think through running my ads and so the
deal was she would get on and then I
would be like this is all the stuff from
last week this is what I have
this is what I'm thinking of doing what
why is it wrong or what would you and
then he I did all the clicking of the
buttons and he would tell me why he
would think about things in different
ways and so that was how I learned how
and it only took me like eight sessions
so I was like now like I didn't have to
go through a course I took eight hours
and I and I learned the scale probably
by the sixth time I was like I'm good
and I just did two more to make sure
that nothing happened yeah and now
you've leveled up your Baseline for how
much money you can earn by having
totally having this so I spent 5600 5600
if I wanted to go run ads for gyms if
that was all I wanted to do and have no
employees I could make 10 20 grand a
month easily if that's all I wanted to
do so like there's you know I mean like
you just keeps adding to your to your
skill set and stacking on top now I also
knew how to sell there so I you know you
stack those two skills together all of a
sudden I'm a hundred thousand dollar a
month skill right so they just keep
multiplying and multiplying and
multiplying nice okay so how old are you
at this point when you just start your
gym and you've signed this 5000 a month
at least 23.
that sounds crazy okay yeah and so you
said that was the riskiest thing that
you've ever like what was going through
your mind at the time if you can
remember for like that because that's a
pretty big big decision not not much not
much honestly I it was ignorance like it
was it was it was
it was I mean I I got lucky you know
what I mean I got lucky that um I didn't
know what I didn't know
I probably would have advised myself to
do that now
um but I was fortunate that I by chance
went to a workshop for I was a marketing
workshop I don't even know his Facebook
ads was even advertised as the thing is
no even knew what they were they'd known
even new Facebook ads were a thing yet
and so I showed up they're like oh
there's these things you can run on and
I didn't I didn't use Facebook I had one
but I didn't like I was like active on I
was like very like productive mindset
like I don't use social media like I was
very big on that whole thing but he was
like oh we can run ads on this so I
learned and it was two weeks before my
gym opened if I had not had that the
plan going into the gym was the guy who
I I apprenticed under he just ran
Groupons
and that was how he got so that was my
whole plan I was like I'll just run a
Groupon and I'll just get people in the
gym from that and I'll convert them that
was his whole business model that was
what I was sold on and then I ran a
Groupon too and I didn't get anybody
no one came in and I ran the same group
on
because I was in the most competitive
part of Southern California I was in
Huntington Beach I was in Orange County
there's a hundred [ __ ] gyms that are
running Groupons and so and he had a he
had a more established business he'd
been doing it for 20 years like he had
you know so when he ran a group on
people all about it every every every
month he was getting like 120 people a
month coming in for Groupons so he was
it was free customer acquisition it was
free he was getting paid to get these
people in the door I didn't have any of
that and so I by chance
went to a workshop two weeks beforehand
and that is only like honestly it's the
only reason I mean who knows I might
have figured I probably would have tried
to figure out another way but it would
have been tough
um you said that quitting your job felt
like the riskiest thing yeah what did
that feel like but
because at that point you were making
like 4K a month off the the personal
training stuff weren't you
so why did you feel particularly risky
but it didn't feel it didn't feel uh
regular it didn't feel consistent I was
like this is one time I don't know how
long this is gonna last you know I mean
like it didn't feel like a regular thing
but it wasn't even that because that
would have been a math decision uh which
at the time it was not a math decision
it was an emotional decision which for
me was I'm leaving the path that I spent
the last however my basically my entire
life leading towards which is management
consulting business school like the
whole thing
um yeah and then you know middle aging
father same deal
um yeah you know he was like this is a
terrible idea
um I strongly disapprove of this and we
didn't talk for a while you know what I
mean um because he's like just Throwing
It All Away
so that was very tough for me it was
that it was just that and I mean at the
end of the day like my my final decision
came down too I mean I gave you the risk
things which is like I'll have a good
story like blah blah blah but I was I
was not really willing to let that be
the story uh because I just didn't want
him to be right and so I was just gonna
do anything to not make him have that I
Told You So moment I just like I was
gonna I was gonna [ __ ] die I just
wasn't gonna do it and so
um the final decision came down to a
point where I was so miserable at the
job that I had because I really didn't
like the job like I was fortunate I
think if I had liked my job I don't know
if I'd even be an entrepreneur I just
really hated the job I was in and so
I dislike the position whatever or at
least that my day to day enough that I
said I would either have to die to him
or die to myself and I felt dead inside
at the time and so I was like I don't
want to continue life living this way I
would rather accept myself and have him
reject me than me reject myself and have
his approval and that was ultimately the
decision that that allowed me to do it
now I was still [ __ ] about it and I
drove halfway across the country before
I called and told him because I didn't
want him to be able to like tell me to
come over to convince me that I could
that I could come back because he did he
was like ah come over for lunch we'll
talk about it because he would always
just like yeah sure you want to we'll
talk about over lunch you know I mean
then you would always talk me off the
cliff off the edge and I was like no I'm
in Ohio
it's like I'm gone
he's like what about your condo and I
was like it's there
and he's like well what are you gonna do
I was like I'll sell it he's like well
you're not gonna sell it I'm gonna have
to deal with it I was like
I'll figure it out you know I was like
I'm gone though I'm not coming back
damn how's how's your relationship with
your dad today I'm good we're good yeah
I mean he's he's proud of me now and
he's happy about all that stuff so I
mean he's got plenty to be proud of in
terms of material success so you can he
can rest easy on that
yeah I had a similar um I think when I
took the decision to leave medicine
after two years of working and you know
at that point my YouTube channel my
YouTube channel is making like way more
than I ever would as a doctor but it's
it still didn't feel like a mathematical
decision it was very much an emotional
thing the whole Asian family like
medicine is like the Pinnacle of all of
the things like 10 years
et cetera and what it took weirdly was
uh I was on uh Lewis hose's podcast yeah
he told me this story and he was he just
like sort of talked me out of it uh
which is bloody hell I've never
considered it in such Stark terms before
and that was what made the decision to
be like you know what let's say goodbye
to Madison at least for a while and see
what happens and yeah it's only for a
while and I can always go back the thing
is once you I mean you have an MD you
can do it I mean you always go back to
it okay so we at this point you are sort
of in your early 20s you've got your gym
you're paying 5K a month and you're
getting people coming in through through
the door to do your six week
transformation program and you're
upselling them on uh the longer term
thing I think after the fact what
happens next in the story the gym starts
being successful gross by five thousand
dollars a month for the first seven
months goes up to thirty five thousand
dollars a month by week by month nine I
had the whole gym outsourced so I was
just managing it by month 15 I took the
profit from that gym to my second Gym
um launched that one
um profitably now this one I learned a
lot at that point so I pre-launched it
at full capacity did you know did it the
right way
um then I opened location three four and
five and then uh using the same concept
then I went and I felt like I was
stagnating I felt like I didn't know
what to do next I joined an internet
Mastermind
um and they were like if you're really
this good at business you shouldn't be
owning gyms you should be like teaching
people how you fill your gyms up so fast
and so then and then I transitioned to
the turn key like I fly out and do the
thing which I make 100 a month on with
no employees I was like this is cool so
I did that for
a year-ish and then um there's a series
a million series of unfortunate events
that happens during this period of time
lose all the money like twice
um I sell the gyms I go all in on the
New Concept we switch from doing the
turnkey system to doing a licensing
model and then that was 2017 and that's
when everything that's when everything
just took off like a rocket
what does it like so let's say someone's
listening to this and they're into
fitness and they're thinking you know
what I'd like to own a gym
what does like is is it something you'd
recommend like can you make any money
owning a gym these days what's what's
the deal with that you can't you can't
you can make money owning a gym if you
love if you you have to love small
business ownership and it has to be
about
um really being in love with the product
and the experience it's just like
you know we have this kind of thing with
a lot of the gyms is once someone
understands how to run a seven figure
multi-seven-figure gym
you now have the skill set to run a 10
million other business
it's just a limited opportunity vehicle
it's a great vehicle to learn how to do
everything because you have to do
everything in a gym and I think some of
the best entrepreneurs are the best
sales people especially learn how to
sell Fitness because you get so many
reps you talk to 10 20 people a day just
rep after rep after like so you get very
good at that and you have to deal with
people because it's an all-service
business so you have a lot of head count
for very low Revenue like there's lots
of things that are very good to learn
when I had the same head count with
TurnKey sales model I had 30 employees
and I was making four times the revenue
you know what I mean and then one went
from there to the licensing model I went
from I took I went from eight employees
to like 30 employees that just like that
first year and we did like seven million
and then the next year we did 26 you
know it was just like it was just huge
growth so it's just more leverage
what does TurnKey mean they didn't have
to do anything I would fly out we do the
marketing we do that we'd spend the
money we'd work the leads we did the
sales like they didn't do after doing it
I just hand them customers
you were confident enough in your
ability to get customers and convert
them to things that they were just
absolutely signing up for this but hell
yes you can transform my gym
yeah
whatever yeah they didn't have to pay me
anything I just took 100 of the cash I
collected
okay so then what are they getting out
of it oh are they are they getting the
recurring Revenue yeah levels of wealth
so you are very open about kind of net
worth and money and stuff and I just
love the way you talk about it in such a
matter of fact way
um one thing that
um I I've been curious about is like
what are the levels of Wealth Beyond
which like you get significant
diminishing returns people say 75k is
the peak happiness and then but like
clearly there are people that you know
300K is better than 75k a million has
been 300 like yeah have you got in mind
a rough sort of ladder of at what level
of wealth's unlock certain certain
things yeah I think there's like the I
don't have to worry about any basic
needs
level
um
and then there's the I don't have to
worry about discretionary spending level
within reason you know what I mean like
I can get I can go out for drinks I can
go to a fancy restaurant and it's not
gonna you know affect me I can buy
appetizers and not just buy you know the
cheapest thing on the menu with no
appetizers no alcohol and call that the
dinner so Layla spends a lot more money
than I do because we just have different
but that being said I spend money on
other stuff so like I spend a lot of
money only on information that's all I
spend my money on it's just information
access like that's all I spend my money
on and that stuff is expensive you know
I mean she offered one guy 350 grand for
an hour
um so I could just learn from him you
know what I mean just for context so
like we'll spend whatever it takes to
learn anything
yeah but like it's always been the
highest return for me so for me it's
just I like sure let's go you know what
I mean like I just I I've made so every
every penny I've made has come from
knowledge and if I can buy someone
else's 10 years and say if I can save a
year of my life for 350 Grand why would
I not spend that you know what I mean so
we've got needs we've got discretionary
spending where you're not worried about
appetizers and stuff what yeah and then
you have what I would consider like
luxury wealth which is probably like you
know 100 Grand a month but it all
depends on what you're willing to save
and so like Layla and I have always
lived on less than 10 of what we make
so whatever we make it's 10 of that is
what we're kind of willing to spend and
I don't even think we spend that now
um we probably spent about five percent
of what we make still a lot of money but
it's not a lot relative because we're
both actually pretty risk-averse but
we're not illogical because some people
I know there's some people in the in the
YouTube space I was having conversation
with their you know clearing clarinet
figures and are like splitting entrees
at dinner I mean dude like you we
literally made more money than this
dinner cost while sitting here you know
what I mean like I was I was having a
conversation with my father-in-law and
he offered to pay for for lunch or
something and I was like while we have
waited in line I have made more money
than this lunch costs let me cover lunch
I don't care
so it really depends on your on your
your savings versus uh spending uh
percentage that you're comfortable with
so that's the big multiplier on those
levels but I think those are the three
levels and it just depends on what that
percentage is for you so if you're a
five to one person I want to make I want
to save 80 spend 20 then your needs
before when you go from needs to uh you
know for level one discretionary you
need to still five extra income to do
that but it's just that that smaller
percentage so I do think that's
individual I'm super risk-averse
ironically so what do you do with a cash
like if you're spending 10 or and sort
of what happens to the other 90 are we
are we now going S P 500 or is that
still like no I I count it
um
we invest but I have a bigger I kind of
a bigger play for what we're going to do
so right now I'm just stacking it and
I've always been a pretty big cash
Decker
um I always have a lot of liquidity I
just feel better with it people like
you're not getting the return I was like
dude I make a ton of money like that's
not like what what am I going to return
for so I would rather have big chunks of
cash that I can go on big offense when I
want it then
it's just different ways of doing things
you know I mean I also have Layla and so
she handles a ton of stuff internally
and so I wouldn't be able to do some of
the investment stuff that we do I
probably wouldn't do something
investment stuff we do right now that
takes a little bit more time like deal
analysis Etc uh if I didn't have her so
like if I didn't have Layla and I was
trying to live the most passive Chill
Lifestyle I'd probably just put
everything into a dividend ETF makes
three four percent a year and still gets
the appreciation and I would just love
paying down or paying up that dividend
check every month and just watching it
go up and it would probably just become
a game for me uh because it's truly
passive you know I mean like that's just
truly zero management passive income
which I do like from a cash flow
perspective and qualified dividends for
anyone who's curious gets taxed at
capital gains rates which are lower so
even if you make a ton of money you're
still only paying you know 20 23
depending on where you're at so
for me I was like okay that works it's
still relatively tax efficient to get
the the cash flow from the from the from
the investment
um but for me though I am going to take
bigger risks with the wealth I have
because
that's the kind of the next level of the
game for me is taking big bets
um so what does what does that look like
broadly you'll see more stuff for me on
the media side
um probably in the in the next 12 to 18.
I'll be probably making really major
investments in media
um because like you know here's a fun
one which you can appreciate from a
YouTube perspective
it cost me like
less than a dollar
or does it cost me a dollar whatever
it's around a buck per subscriber per
month now I'm taking my entire media
team cost which goes across all
platforms which is not really fair but
if I were to if I even took that whole
media team and put it against YouTube
um it cost me around a dollar-ish a
month per subscriber
and I make more than a dollar a year per
subscriber just in AdSense
so like from a return you know what I
mean like that doesn't include like what
I actually make money which is fine you
know my deal Flow side
um
so it's you know I mean it's like well
then I should you know put my money
there and I will be I'll be taking
bigger and bigger chunks of companies uh
right now we do minority deals but I
will be taking majority uh interesting
companies where it makes sense uh so
it's like if I see a company that makes
sense within the entire portfolio so
I'll give an example so like if somebody
has an accounting firm it would be great
to just have the accounting at holtco
and I'll just buy a hundred percent and
then I can provide those Services
internally and then because of the
buying power that I have between the
entire kind of conglomerate for lack of
better term you know if I have
you know 200 250 million dollars a year
in in business that I can push towards
something it's like I'm not going to
push that kind of money towards
something that I don't own majority of
at least so those are kind of the two
directions that I'll probably go and
it's just reinvesting more in the team
um and you know taking I mean from a
from a money allocation perspective more
of that would go towards the majority
purchases than the team but that's just
you know fundamentally how I see it like
I'll get better Returns on that stuff
than I will in the s p and I have to
take if I want to get to a billion I
have to make some bigger bets which is
fine what's the goal here is the goal to
get to a billion like what is it 10
billion yeah the goal is to get to 10
billion
um but the the mission is to just make
real business knowledge available for
everyone
and so that's that's what I'm trying to
do and so everything I do at lunch
that's why I make the books so I make
the courses that's why we do the YouTube
stuff that's why we make the shorts
that's why we do podcasts that's why we
do all of it
um it's just to make real business
education available to everyone but I
have to answer the question why should I
listen to you and I want to be
unassailable in that perspective a and
then B I do believe that I'll gain more
perspective as as things grow so it's
more than I'm just curious what I'm
going to learn going from you know 200
million portfolio to a billion dollar
year portfolio to a 10 billion dollar
your portfolio and so I have wished that
Jeff Bezos and Elon Musk and Warren
Buffett will come out of the course I
wouldn't that be amazing but they didn't
and so my goal is to just document the
path that we learn along the way
um and you know when I die hopefully
there'll just be a whole bunch of people
who are younger than me who make way
more money than I do at my age because
they were able to just shortcut a lot
why is that the mission like I'm making
business education available like what
was the kind of emotional resonance with
you for that thing because that's what
set me through
freezing free from the corporate wage
slavery yeah not even corporate ways
like I'm free I can do whatever I don't
have to do anything
if I didn't want to so I just get I just
get optionality which is all I want I
just want to have options
and so I wouldn't have that if all of
this stuff didn't exist and I have had
many mentors and many coaching programs
and many courses and so you know I would
say that I differ from the vast majority
of the talking heads in the business
space in that I to my knowledge I'm the
only one who came up through that world
like you look at Andy for sale you look
at my life you look at Gary you know
what I mean like there's there's they've
none of them came up through learning
stuff on YouTube going to seminars going
to coaching programs I did
so I'm a huge advocate for the for for
alternative education and you know
paying for skills as fast as you can
to what extent do you think about the
balance between I guess optimizing for
freedom freedom fun flexibility all of
that like living whatever life you want
kind of Vibes versus some people say
that once you get to a certain point you
realize that oh actually more money more
status more success more freedom is not
actually thing and actually the thing I
care about is investing in a
relationship and like having a family
and having kids and like buying a house
and the sort of putting down routes
versus having wings kind of vibe I have
options so if I change my mind I can
change my mind
um but as I see it right now from where
I said the thing that lights me up every
day is is making business knowledge
available to everyone and I mean I spend
an inordinate amount of time
like I spend so much time on those books
and presentations that I make when I
give speeches and stuff like every
presentation I make up to this point in
my career has been custom and that takes
me like three days you don't need to
make a presentation so like if you've
seen Last Dance Michael Jordan
there's this there's this moment where
he says that he always has to bring his
all because it's the there's some person
who spent hard-earned money and it's the
only game they're ever going to see and
he wants to bring his best for that
and so that's how I see it you know I
mean like there's people who will never
you know they spent real money to be
there and it was like they're hoping
that they can get one thing from this
thing that's gonna like change their
life
and I want to honor that
what is like a day in the life look like
for you oh it's I mean I could share my
screen but it's it's it's it's uh I I I
work on my own stuff until about one
most days so usually five to one is Alex
time to do whatever
um which is on 5am to one yeah
um and then usually from one to four on
to 4 30ish is when I do meetings
and then um
that's it
go to the gym eat
and then I'm done
sounds pretty chill and where are you
based at the moment we're all over right
now uh The Hub is in Vegas but we're
here
we're all over I mean we travel a lot so
it's kind of like this is our in between
when we're traveling spot
I remember you just talking into me
about like how you like your office to
be very like sparse and not overly fancy
and stuff and that's one of the things
that really I really Vibe with with in
your in your videos and that you seem to
I I except until recently uh you seem to
just be filming on some shitty webcam
and just like spouting knowledge and
it's just like mind-blowing because you
haven't got the and there's like a charm
to the junkiness and it's just like whoa
[ __ ] I'm I'm getting the real truth
without any of the production value that
like normally gets in the way yeah again
was that deliberate is that just
accidental is that just how it's ended
up being I mean that's how it started
you know I mean like I'm a big I'm a big
believer and just start and you'll the
path eliminates as you walk you know I
mean we now have I mean I started
without a media team so I just clicked
record and I would send it I mean I had
my media team at gymwatch but it wasn't
that business wasn't built on content it
was built on outbound and pay that so I
just said you know CL you know clip it
put a thumbnail on it and post it on my
YouTube I don't even know how to upload
them just to show you how silly it was I
was like just upload it and so I just
put in a Dropbox and they would upload
it and then that was um that was what I
did for the first I don't know six nine
months and then um we hired somebody to
uh to actually do recordings with the
camera
um and so he's like you know if we did
it like on the couch it would look a lot
better I was like okay that's fine so it
took the same amount of time for me now
I just had some more people who could
who could help and it has shown despite
you know as much as I would lament you
know I would love to just do it like
this the uh you know the audio quality
is better the video quality is better
um and the newer videos definitely do
better from a objective standpoint so
some people need to you know can't focus
this long and so they need a little bit
more
um happening and so we can now again the
whole point is to make it available to
everybody so that means that people who
don't have the attention span I need to
make something available for them so
um
so I'm just doing my best to I'm just
not going to [ __ ] and moan about the
fact that like people's attention's been
short and like some people like I I
can't cover anything in 60 seconds I'm
like there's a hell of a lot you can
cover in 60 seconds if you know what
you're saying so you know what I mean
like I
I'm just not I just I'm just not one to
complain about what it is what it is and
so I will do my best to match
you know providing value to the context
that
that people are consuming it it seems
like you're spending like I don't know
half a million a month on content no no
no no no no no no no no not even close I
think we're spending about 100 a month
oh okay maybe it's a one dollar per
subscriber per month is what it's
costing you yeah per year I make a
dollar per year oh per year oh okay cool
I was thinking like per month for [ __ ]
that's a lot yeah no my channel makes I
think as of today like right now it
makes 41 42 000 a month and then Layla's
Layla also use the same team I think
hers makes six or seven something like
that so that's just that and then the
book the book Revenue comes on top of
that which I count those kind of the
same thing because I think that's where
a lot of people find us those two things
together you know are more than that so
I am I technically spend a little bit
less uh than I'm making which kind of
further reinforces the point
um just depends if we're just saying
only AdSense if we include the book
whatever
so what does 100K a month like oh what
does what does that look like at the
back end of the content production
engine yeah it's not huge right now
we've got four in-house
um I still do Twitter so I do Twitter
full-time that's still just me
um it's because I like it I would do it
anyways we have a a podcast vendor a
LinkedIn vendor uh YouTube vendor
um
a short slash Tick Tock slash reels
vendor and by and by vendor you mean
like uh a company that yeah okay
now we have our internal components
because like my whole Playbook is is
pretty simple which is go find the best
person who's already doing this at a
high level pay whatever to get them to
do it be clear that your intention is to
take it in-house over the Long Haul
starting with them only hire somebody to
be the the inner inner
the interface between those two who has
the skill set and then eventually get to
the point where you double your volume
because you do half from the vendor half
from the in-house person when the
in-house person beats the vendor you
fire the vendor and so what does it look
like to work with like an agency on the
YouTube side are they telling you that
hey Alex we need to do a video with this
title and this thumbnail go talk or like
what does that look like so my team does
it so because remember because I haven't
asked team too so they will they'll send
me
like I could show you a document but
it's like the next film session they
have like eight ideas for videos I'll
just pick the three that I'm feeling
um
and so they have like uh headline idea
talking points that they've grabbed from
my other videos and shorts that they've
kind of combined together into one video
um and I use that as a loose outline uh
for what I'm going to talk about it has
to be minimum and this is one of the
things that my team gets it's like
it has to be minimal on my side because
I'm still doing other stuff you know
what I mean um
so yeah that's my that's the that's the
big big and so is the is is part of as
part of the overall mission of making
business knowledge accessible to
everyone it's part of that like you
getting as big as possible in all the
social platforms as quickly as possible
with as much content as possible like
the garyvee model yeah probably 100 nice
we're still not even like we're barely
scratching what I would consider to be
phase one of that but we're on just
phase one what are the next few phases
we're right now we're just getting all
the platforms uh then we need to
maximize all the platforms which we're
currently not doing uh we have to take
it all in-house so we have to do that
which we haven't done yet
um I'm not running any paid of any kind
um which I would add on I don't have any
Affiliates or endorsements which I would
add on
um I don't have any like in terms of
level of content I would like to do some
more like custom production stuff that's
more show-ish than just like
you know seven ways to make a million
dollars without any money so those are
kind of like the direction of where I'd
like to go uh with it and it'll just
it'll take time and that's fine like
great things take time and do you think
at all about sort of pitching certain
content like like for example pitching
it to a complete beginner who's never
even heard a business versus pitching it
to someone who here's how to level up
your sales which is a bit more advanced
like how do you think of that balance
um it's a discussion that we actually
have internally a lot so I believe
because our beliefs shape our world that
we can make content that helps both
so 100 million dollar offers if you
don't know what to sell that will help
you if you sell shitloads of stuff it
will help you
so I do believe that if you
I think there's if if things are
packaged and presented properly
uh like sales to your to your point
could I make a half step and just call
it persuasion and all of a sudden it's
not sales guys it's sales guys marketers
and general population that want to
influence people
so all of a sudden it becomes a much
more open topic so I'm trying to think
about all the like this is what I'm
actually like this is today Alex is what
I'm thinking about right now because I
think that they're and you know this
better than I do but this is just my
inkling is that there's a natural
ceiling that start you start to approach
now we're we haven't seen any slowdown
at all but like I would imagine that
there's a ceiling that you begin to
approach as you start to kind of own I
don't say own but like take up a Big
Slice of like brain brain share of a
certain Niche right yeah and so the only
way to expand beyond that and I think
I've uh you know I've known people who
went from sales to Marketing sales to
business to make money you know what I
mean so they just go they go broader and
broader but I think if you have the
depth of knowledge behind you you can
make something wide yet also deep so
that's a belief that I'm choosing right
now is that we can do both we can make
content that is wide and deep
it's just harder but I think we can do
it so that is what I'm committing to
if you were to start the whole content
thing again like from scratch
um what are what are some things that
you might do differently I would have
started five years ago
that's what I would have done the only
thing I could wish for is for things to
happen faster the only thing that would
happen faster is if I started earlier so
that's that's it but then there's also
the caveat of like I have credibility
now that I didn't have five years ago so
I mean you could make the argument I did
I could probably show my tax return When
I was 27 show 17 million dollars of
income like I could show that I could
have done that
um
maybe I don't know I could have but like
I don't I honestly don't spend much time
thinking about it I'm content with
what we're doing now
um we know what plan we have to execute
and so now we're just we're just laying
the bricks
final thing I wanted to ask you about so
I think I think I heard you say in one
of the interviews that you've had six
pack abs since the age of like 16 or
something something like that
um
no oh love it
I I've had six pack abs on my kind of
annual bucket list for the last several
years and just never really gotten there
is there like a single resource there's
a lack of knowledge or it's a lack of
knowledge or motivation
motivation
okay well that's that's a totally
different thing yeah I mean like you
might you might also want to be a
trillionaire you might want a lot of
things but like if you don't want it
enough it doesn't matter I think it's
just more accepting that you're not
going to have it you're not willing to
pay the price and that's fine what is
the price you would want to be motivated
foreign
it's not that hard though that's why I'm
like yeah
um and everyone is who's listening is
like [ __ ] this guy
um I don't know I've counted my macros
for 20 years have you okay uh so go away
uh but but it's just calorie deficit you
know I mean it's just it's like there's
tons of people in Africa who have six
packs they just don't see the stats
there it's just everyone's everyone's
skinny you know what I mean and so six
pack is purely body fat percentage
that's it it's just body fat percentage
it just means you eat too much that's
all and a six-packed plus being jacked
is Progressive overload protein I've
seen one of your videos where you sort
of break break that down and then to get
to six-pack abs you just sort of calorie
deficit and while training broadly it's
lit I mean truly that is it and so
like I've hit every muscle group do it
three times a week add weed or reps Over
the Bar over a long period of time
that's all you have to do and then eat
less than you burn do that for a long
period of time you'll gain muscle you'll
lose fat and then you'll look up after
18 months you'll have a six-pack if I
could just that's it
yeah when people are signing up to the
weight loss programs or like a gym
program and stuff
presumably they know this so like
is it that like the motivation Gap the
accountability Gap like what is it that
is the the secret sauce that makes
someone so to your to your point even of
alternative education in general when
you say Hey you could learn the stuff on
YouTube etc etc the issue that we're
solving for is not that it's not a
knowledge Gap the issue is an
accountability Gap is that people don't
do stuff like that is the primary issue
with all humans in general is that they
will not endure short-term discomfort
for a long-term achievement that is it
you hack that you hack success that's
all it is and so it's just how can I how
can I make it more inconvenient for them
to not follow than to follow
so I can still lean into their humidity
and just say how can I make it more
uncomfortable for them to not follow it
that's an element of that is
accountability is that someone says Hey
bad boy
um you had a cookie when you shouldn't
have you feel bad feel bad I am
punishing you because like the only way
to change you only have two things you
can do to change Behavior right you can
reinforce or you can threaten you can
punish that's it you have carrots and
sticks that is literally it and so
currently they're getting reinforced by
their you know by their current way of
living so think about this way what does
not having six-pack do for you it does
something for you because you keep
buying it
what does not having a six-pack do for
me yeah because you mean something else
over a six-pack so yeah the food the
food just tastes too good and I know
that I should yeah but it's probably not
and I get a McDonald's drive through at
like midnight and I know it's bad and
like it could be convenient convenience
and then the story you wrap around like
I'm an entrepreneur I need to just do
things on my own time Etc right so I
think if you if like it's unpacking
those things of just trying to find your
own [ __ ] and or if it if it's
meaningful for you because like I
understand why it wouldn't be I was on
this podcast that I got an argument with
the the spokesperson who's like don't
you agree that every entrepreneur should
be working every day and I was like no
and it did not go the direction he was
expecting he looks at me and he expects
I'm going to say that I'm like no like
what are we solving for if you just want
to live a long time then just walk walk
and don't eat a lot like that's all you
have to do like literally it that's all
you have to do if you don't live the
longest amount possible like I am going
to live a shorter amount of time because
I have more muscle mass I'm shortening
My Life by being how big I am
so it just depends on what's what
problem we're solving
but given how you look now you could you
could look
fit in 12 months like you could look
like a person that people are like oh
wow this guy works out
because you don't have a baseline effect
that you really left I mean you do you
have you have body fat but like you're
not you're not overweight you're just
you have your body composition is poor
not poor but you I'm saying it's not
it's not what you want I know you're
saying yeah nice so figure out what you
want uh find out what the price is and
just be willing to pay that price uh
yeah or don't which is also fine I don't
buy everything that I see on the Shelf
if it were free I'd want it right maybe
if I were you know a hoarder of some
sort but like like the thing that
everybody has is we all have a wallet
with the same dollars in it we have 24
right and so it's like everything has a
ticket on it and we're just choosing to
spend that dollar whatever we want now
eight dollars we got to spend on on
sleep it's like okay well now I only
have you know 16 left I'm like all right
well what does this cost well this cost
a dollar it's pretty every day I'm
committing to a dollar of my twelve
dollars or whatever my my 16 it's a big
cost
does it make sense
coming back to the six-pack example
again like how much time effort do you
how how many dollars do you pay each day
to maintain the six-pack minimal I have
a passive income body now
okay fine I already yeah this is this is
passive dividends I don't need to do
much to maintain this to get to here is
much harder to maintain here is easy I
mean think about this how much effort
does it cost you right now to maintain
your current body oh zero absolutely
right that's how it really does not take
like unless you give your body a reason
to eat muscle it's been a lot of
resources to to build it right and so
you can have minimal stimulation on a
weekly basis
to maintain contractile tissue and
provided your eating sufficient protein
your body will take the protein it needs
from your intake rather than its stores
of protein which is your muscle
I mean you if you watch the video
there's it's like you just
um a pound a pound a day of mate or
something yeah yeah
nice Alex thank you so much this has
been absolutely wonderful um any any
final asks for the audience who might be
watching or listening to this
if you like watching stuff you can check
out my YouTube channel Alex stromoza you
can just Google my name
um and if you are listening then you can
also search my name um Alexi and my
podcast called the game will come up and
you can check that out uh so loved it
love to hang out with you more if if
that uh that sounds like the pants that
you want to wear and uh hopefully I'll
see you or talk to you soon Amazing Alex
thank you so much and if you're ever in
London anytime soon would be great to do
a round two in person uh yeah that would
be awesome yeah epic all right I
appreciate you thanks so much man take
care all right so that's it for this
week's episode of Deep dive thank you so
much for watching or listening all the
links and resources that we mentioned in
the podcast are going to be linked down
in the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye